بنايه متحركه تحت ظن ثلاث مدارس
عمرها نحو 70 عاما
وتضم اكثر من الفي طالب
يصل عدد الطلاب في الصف الواحد الى 100
والدراسه في واحده من هذه المدارس الثلاث
لا تتعدى الساعتين فقط بسبب الارتباط
ان نقص الشديد في عدد الابنيه المدرسيه
اصبح واقعه حال في العراق
وقله المخصصات الماليه للتعليم معضله اخرى
[موسيقى]
في هذه السنين الماضيه من قله في التخصصات
الماليه وهذا اثر على عدد الابناء
المدرسيه الموجوده في في الوزاره وكذلك
تاهيل المدارس المتعلقه والعاليه للصقور
هنا في احدى القرى بمنطقه ابو غريب
الضاحيه الغربيه لبغداد تم انشاءه هذه
المدرسه من عدد من الكرفانات
منشئه المدرسه عام 2017
لتكون بديلا لهذا المبنى الذي تهدم في
سنوات الحرب ضد تنظيم الدوله هذه الحاله
ليست الوحيده
فهناك مدارس مشابهه في عدد من المحافظات
تلاميذ 519 عدد المحاضرين ثمانيه المدرسه
لا يواجه تحديات كبيره اهمها استمرار وجود
اكثر من مليون طفل خارج المدارس اضافه الى
الدمار الذي قال البنيه التحتيه لمعظم
ابنيه المدرسيه
المتوفر حاليا لقطاع التعليم غير كافي من
الناحيه الماديه والفنيه بما هو موجود على
ارض الواقع لذلك تسعى اليونسكو دائما على
الحصول على التمويل من الجهات المانحه من
اجل العمل همم مع الوزارات المعنيه على سد
هذه الثغرات
تقول اليونسكو ان عدم القدره على تحمل
نفقات التعليم في العراق يمثلوا 30 في
المئه من التحديات التي تواجه تطوير هذا
القطاع وترى المنظمه الدوليه ان الحله
يكمن في المساهمه برفع مداخيل الاسر
المعنيه ما يسمح باعاده التحاق ابنائها
بصفوف الدراسه
وليد ابراهيم الجزيره بغداد